hi and welcome I imagine there are
really good sessions running in parallel
to this one so thank you all for
choosing that one I'll do my best not to
disappoint it's a little bit of a
bizarre setup right because you on both
sides and I'm not entirely sure who to
face so I'm gonna be fidgeting a lot
okay so about a year and a half ago two
things two major things happened in
happened to me in my life well one I
became a father thank you
firstly mostly to my wife not to me so I
had a little bit of time on my hands
right I took off some time of work and
the second thing that happened to me is
I returned to programming racquet for
the nth time so no sleep some time I was
looking for a smallish project that was
not completely useless right hopefully
maybe web-related even though I'm not I
was not ready to buy into this whole web
tech thing so something simple so I
looked around there's a very
unscientific but actually very
scientific estimate of mine that say for
heavy load of ads maybe 90% perhaps and
more websites even today could be served
perfectly fine by just a handful of CGI
scripts right and for those of you who
may not know or haven't been around CGI
the protocol and its extensions like
fancy gif for instance is kind of how we
try to attempt it to do dynamic web
programming around 1990s yeah it's it's
kind of our PC style so the request
comes in your web server Maps it on to
the file system run script from there
whatever this spits out in to the
standardout is sent back to the client
as a response now as you can imagine
this is not cheap right because if for
every request you need to do all of the
shebang then
well so fast Ajay emerged as a sort of a
smallish binary protocol and a simple
extension to CGI in an attempt to remedy
this yeah so your script typically sits
in the background talking over TCP
socket with your webserver and hold on
to all of those external connections
things like that now to my surprise
right
I couldn't find a fast EDI
implementation for Rekha there are other
external protocols that were implemented
but not passage I what happened next
I can probably atribute either to severe
baby induce sleep deprivation or maybe
brain damage or perhaps both of them
right I thought how hard would it be to
implement one well it turns out not hard
at all and you don't need a fancy list
to do it unless of course you go off on
a tangent which exactly what I did and
it's just a pretext and you end up
hacking a bunch of languages write
something about lisps that makes that
sort of procrastination a ton of fun and
you may have experienced it yeah you set
out to solve a problem and proceed to
language hacking or perhaps hacking your
editor if you happen to be using Emacs
right it sucks you in all the while the
problem you were set out to solve in the
first place kind of sits there waiting
for better time maybe a bit but a
framework perhaps better language right
in my case so if we honest we tend to do
this because it's a ton of fun because
we can and that's exactly what we're
going to do here we'll pretend we want
to implement Farsi GI and then
procedures or to do some language
hacking now the typical defense is kind
of we all heard it right it goes
something like I'm implying it I'm gonna
implement this ultimate DSL with this
particular problem domain in mind once I
have it I'm gonna solve this problem in
two lines of code it'll be a thing of
beauty
right it's a
typical defense very weak one but it's
not without merit
like no low-level solution will ever
come close to your custom build DSL with
that problem in mind now that of course
predicated on your ability to get the
design the architecture even the syntax
of the language just right right the
crux of the problem though is if you
think programming is hard and I tend to
think that programming is not easy
design is that much harder just think
about the last time you had to fight a
very broken API and it's not like you
can well you kind of you can't blame the
author obviously but it's not like they
had this malicious intent to ship this
broken thing is just that getting it
right is difficult you're designing so
why is it so hard especially when you
design a language or you design an open
system you haven't built you haven't
seen anything like that before why why
is it so difficult especially its if
it's meant to be extensible so I
implemented a bunch of languages when
DSL Xinbo thin in racket and enclosure
and it got me thinking this summer time
around like why is it difficult
typical approaches when you design
something like this is either bottom-up
or top-down and in my experience
bottom-up is perhaps the most practiced
practice technique if a good reason
right you start very small and
manageable pieces your feedback loop is
rather tight you can even go
systematically about it if you subscribe
to test-driven development right then so
the way you start to implement things is
you zoom in to the parts and you
implement the pieces that you can
actually conceive and make them compile
and run so very often you just cobble
together a bunch of stuff that's already
available as external dependencies right
things like that the problem of course
is when you zoom out and you start
implement the rest of the system you
haven't seen the system but something is
already running your tests are green so
great
yeah but the problem is there's external
dependencies they kind of force you into
a certain design already because they
provide API you have to use that API you
haven't played with any of it but you
have those building blocks your system
compiles tests a green you happy
so you proceeded as if nothing happened
that means bottom-up kind of forces you
into a design whether it's a good design
of bad design who knows but it somehow
works out in the end most of the time
that is another way of putting it is
I'd say bottom-up kind of it's it
precludes you can't really let your
imagination run wild right take the
wheel a little bit play around with the
system it's not that kind of thing so at
this point most people would go
bottom-up pretty much every time right
and I can't really fault them because
programming has a deal with so much and
so many unknowns that it's perfectly
fine to seek solace wherever you can get
it like your it compiles your tests
agree in what's not to like I noticed
that at least when I racket racket
language I tend to go if I'm designing a
language or oppa will work on something
that's not small and I haven't worked
before I tend to go the other way around
top-down now what do I mean by that I
imagine that I have a language already
in place I sit down I start typing start
I start writing playing with a whole
system now obviously I don't have that
language on my machine it doesn't run
there's nothing on my machine but I do
have it in my head some approximation of
it surely right because I have it I can
play with it it's actually so I would
say that this approach is the kind of is
almost an act of writing you sit down
you write the style dependent paper
style but with a laptop and a bunch of
other constrain
now I keep saying top down but really I
encountered this kind of technique and
I'm gonna call it technique very early
in my programming days how many people
recognized where this is coming from all
right how many not many sicp lectures
right available on YouTube if you
haven't watched them you're in for a
treat
it's good enough for apples Anna Sussman
what they call well what I call top-down
and we tend to call top-down they called
wishful thinking and record it would be
hash language for thinking or something
like that right so the essence of what
they suggested I think as wishful
thinking is pretend you have it all
pretend you have semantics syntax all
the building blocks you need and proceed
and with an attempt of implementing your
system as if you have all of it and hope
that it's somehow is going to work out
now trouble is our languages are kind of
ill-prepared for that sort of thing yeah
you we are supposed to be we're supposed
to use the what minimal building blocks
they provide means of combination and
abstraction for any problem no matter
the problem you can employ this
technique in the small so long as you're
happy with those building blocks it
doesn't help that I'd say most people
are a little bit unprepared to not
having a running system not having it
compile no tests right it's just it's
scary so like I said top-down kind of
calls for an act of writing and the
reason we can do this in some lisps I'm
not going to say in all lisps because
macro system well maybe in all that's
actually because there is a macro system
that kind of has your back every time I
think this is no surprise that this
should come up in the context of scheme
right where you have a powerful macro
system that kind of has your back every
time in that you can you can macro any
idea into submission
it doesn't validate your idea
right but it sure is anima 'putin tool
to have in your toolbox
it lets you I think it lets you play a
little bit like loosen your grip like
shake off the constraints that language
put on you so some lists can help they
provide you with a bunch of tools right
out of the box like for instance you can
count on having a reader so you don't
have to pass as hard as long as you are
happy staying in the s-expression land
which I'm content with if you're lucky
maybe they even pass in to reach syntax
objects not just lists they give you a
decent enough macro system maybe even
hygienic one by default and they work as
long as you're on the happy path what do
I mean by the happy path the experience
of using the end result that you produce
the language or the DSL the extension to
language something like this right
because and it's a gnarly problem
because when you're homegrown DSL blows
up as it inevitably will it will be a
new user space like chances are in your
garden-variety list I'll be staring at a
wall of code I've never written with
very few tools at my disposal to help me
on the path of resolving this now there
are other lists that are perhaps more
demanding on you is the implementer but
they make more ambitious macros possible
and therefore more ambitious DSL as
possible and at the same time hopefully
the result more habitable yeah so
perhaps in addition to all these things
they give you let's say macros that
communicate actual hooks into the
compiler languages that can coexist call
each other
cooperate write maybe even the entire
platform built with multilingual
ecosystem in mind so this is the
ambitious part the habitable habitable
part is well maybe at the very minimum
they ensure that there is enough context
implicitly received or explicitly
defined by you specified by you
at the very minimum they lift the error
messages to your homegrown language so
your user doesn't get lost now racket is
one such language it's probably not the
only one but to the best of my knowledge
it's probably one of the rare ones that
push those meta programming ideas the
farthest and in this show in this talk
we shall speak racket if you don't know
it don't fret as long as you're
comfortable looking at a little bit of
less on the screen you should be okay my
I want to through an example show you
some basic glimpse at some basic ideas
that are still quite powerful in racket
ok so how many of you actually know
racket whew ok how many of you have
heard about racket oh good nice all
right you haven't okay great well let me
give my very distinct Radek take on
racket and I'm sure a lot of racketeers
will disagree but this is mine I'm
taking the stage I can do it all right I
can I'm not gonna go on Wikipedia style
on you yeah it's multi-paradigm yeah you
can bring any paradigm you want it
already has a lot of them and I'm not
even gonna quote the founding fathers of
racket it is a programming language
programming language but without any
context or first-hand experience this
sounds really cool and delightful but
kind of a and if this sort of thing
makes you curious I employ you to seek
out and read the so-called record
manifesto you can even watch mr. Dyson
the father of racket talk about it
online only on YouTube it's a different
kind of manifesto not your typical one
in that it's not so much a declaration
of intent or call to arms it's it's like
I'd say 30 plus years of experience
building racket and it's a coding system
distilled into one text it's it's a good
read now as far as I'm concerned this
here's one defining feature of racket
pick a language any language and show me
some feature you really like chances are
I can steal it I can steal it I can
bring it to racket make perhaps even
likely improve on it in fact other
languages will make appearance in this
talk Lua closure prominently and I'll
even mention Erlang as source of
inspiration
I myself happen to be a closure
programmer this is where the money comes
from
but racket is my first love this is in
fact the language that I use to teach
myself programming back in the day so I
keep returning to it and every time I do
is from somewhere else so I bring those
ideas that I liked to the language and
the macro kind of has my back closure
programmers in the audience okay
way more than rickety is good I'm gonna
lean a little bit on that knowledge in
my opinion closure is kind of what
happens when you decide to tackle this
really gnarly problem enterprise
programming and you succeed it's a cool
language I really like it it's very
pragmatic it comes with some very
tasteful defaults economics is great
data is front and center platform gives
you a lot of batteries out-of-the-box
battle-tested batteries unfortunately
platform is also what limits it I think
now racket is what happens when you
decide to build the second best language
in the world and succeed there is a
punchline here I'm quoting when he is
realizing by the way the punchline goes
something like this
chances are the best language in the
world will be built in racket think
about what this implies because this
will inform your design the features
that make it into the language you are
setting out to build the ultimate
platform for building their cells right
so necessarily meta programming becomes
front and center it's not the only
feature of the language obviously but
that's what it makes it pass
now there are two interesting features
that make that made it I believe into
the language from almost probably from
day one pedagogy and research now I am
but a humble consumer research I read
papers I sometimes implement them but
now that I'm a father suddenly pedagogy
matters a whole lot more I'm happy it's
there now languages are prominent of
course in racket like every snippet on
the screen is some kind of language
essentially right so think of it as a
separate file that uses a very different
language compared to everything else
right if you if you if the end users of
your language happen to be happen either
don't care for brands or hate them you
can go without if you don't want to now
as far as full-on languages go it's all
in this first line right that starts
with hash lang now with it you provide
both the reader and the expander for
what follows what do I mean by the
reader how the hell am I supposed to
read this thing that follows really
expander is the meaning of what I just
read what's the semantics of all those
identifies that I just encountered
that's about it that's not to say that
racket
is not big on embedded ESL's like that
work small deer cells that work at
expression level at forum level right in
fact they're pervasive they're
everywhere in racket that first line is
a DSL and a user extensible one at that
racket provides requires the way you
import/export stuff right loops
comprehensions beautiful racket pattern
matching facility with racket match all
their cells all user extracted
extensible now practically speaking what
I think is what I think makes meta
programming in racket special it takes
its roots in scheme so all the usual
suspects are there compiler deals with
rich syntax objects that track a bunch
of stuff location obviously but also
compilers aware of bindings so scopes
are explicit it keeps track of those
scopes in fact you can slice and dice
them you can take this context borrow it
from one place
slap it somewhere else talk about
breaking hygiene systematically stages
of compilation are explicit very often
sputter spelled out that means
metaprogramming sort of to the nth power
possible it is feasible if you head over
to racket website specifically to
documentation very surprisingly quite
inconspicuously there some somewhere
there is a link to syntax
metaprogramming helpers this is where
the real power is it will teach you all
about syntax pause frameworks index
classes that sort of thing and in a
typical racket passion it's just a
language this is a sort of a glimpse of
it I'm I'm not gonna teach you the this
framework so all I do here is define a
bunch of syntax classes like hole there
which I'm gonna use down below in the
actual macro that's this threading
lambda thing now what are those syntax
classes well they take a bunch of
parameter they take it but a bunch of
patterns that I specify and those help
compile I decide how to parse whatever
happened is happening in the in the
macro and then reach it with some
context that I can explicitly extract
and provide or it implicitly in reaches
what the result of reading with that
context that becomes really powerful
that is to say that in racket very often
you start writing your macros in their
cells by extending the language for
writing macros and ESL's so in record it
is kind of Turtles all the way somewhere
so we we I give you a little bit of a
backstory and then completely go off on
a tangent of this layer right we talked
about the top-down approach so a bit of
philosophy there some meta programming
stuff I even mentioned I promised you I
mentioned closure I mentioned closure
I'll probably mention it a little more
we'll see
so we'll actually do something right
let's start implementing faster GI so
it's a small speck it hasn't changed
since 96
in 1996 it's a binary protocol it was
meant to be extensible but
unlikely right at this point so there
are two problems we need to solve one
since it's a binary protocol we're on
the wire we need to pass and pack those
bytes yeah the second problem actually
modeling the protocol we need to program
it right so let's solve the first one
the passing bit and packing bit so it is
a sequence of byte you start by parsing
passage a header it will tell you one of
the bytes will tell you what type of a
message you are looking at and you
proceed passing it accordingly right it
becomes a little more involved because
parameters of the request have passed on
the same wire they encoded his name
value pairs and they could be they were
trying to save bandwidth so they thought
it would be a good idea to allow to
encode them as 1 by the 4 bytes the way
you decide which it is is by looking at
the most significant bit right how do
you normally approach that sort of thing
what do we normally do something like
that right you go bitwise arithmetic
shifting adding orange sorry
masking that fun stuff cryptic values
with acts before them like what the hell
are those feast your eyes on this
there's a good cold bad code
esthetically is it pleasing the moment i
wrote this i thought i'm parsing name
value pairs that i mentioned the moment
i wrote this i thought something's off i
should i mean ok it is a programming
language you could be writing python a c
in it but that's what you end up with
well the larger problem is not that it
doesn't have error checking there it
doesn't I promise it's that and it's
just part of the code they're not the
bigger problem for me is that this is
not what I have have in my head at all I
don't think in bitwise arithmetic
maybe after years and Sealand doing some
systems programming or implementing TCP
stack I would I don't I have boxes with
zeros and ones and a match on them right
there are some patterns in my head that
I'm gonna use so briefly I actually
considered and I sat down and I sketched
out how I would write a pattern matching
facility a language of bit patterns but
then found out that someone beat me to
it
and honestly I couldn't be happier
because I suck at with twiddling I mean
I can do it but I would have to get a
refresher so a a very prominent
racketeer toni Garrn ik Jones looked
around and that will be a theme of this
talk he looked around and rickety at one
from Alang he reimagined that as this
beautiful library called bit syntax
that's all it takes to parse and pack
farxiga headers that's all it takes to
pause parameters now there is one thing
that stands out which is obviously not
part of bit syntax that fcj length there
that's a pattern a custom pattern so my
extension to the language it's just a
matter of writing a small macro whose
essence is in these two cases I told you
you need to look at the most significant
bit look at that very first pattern it's
kind of obvious what I'm doing this is
the the scheme way the racket way so of
course it's a programming language you
can write anything you want in it but
please don't write Python or something
that's that I have to caveat this right
fancy guy being very simple protocol it
doesn't warrant this amount of work
right but if you're tasked with three
implementing TCP stack you may as well
take your time okay let's zoom out a
little bit time to model the protocol
itself now this being a protocol
with an actual spec that's unlikely to
ever be extended I wishful thinking is
nice and all but it works well for
designing a language or an open system
let's face it so it doesn't really
warrant this sort of approach but so I
went with a mix I leaned a little bit on
my very rough at the time understanding
of racket structs and the simple
inheritance model that they provide and
racket generics yeah so what I did I sat
down and I sketched out the entire
system having made some some simple
assumptions about how inheritance works
and all that sort of things it was
beautiful
and very extensible even though protocol
will never be extended because why not I
was having fun and then I zoomed in and
started implementing smaller pieces
using racket structs and relying on
generics and the entire system starts to
come undone like my beautiful sketch
very quickly turned into this Franken
monster why is it the wishful thinking
thing I think the problem was those
constraints were too severe for the
sketch that I designed for the design in
my head they were too severe but it
wasn't a total waste because I it kind
of hinted me hinted at what I wish I had
and what I wish I had was a kind of a
more nimble datatype that would let me
sketch and prototype quickly that would
afford more generously those inheritance
patterns that I had in my head right
that sort of thing what does it mean
time to go rig it hearing now I was
playing with this nifty little language
at the time called Lua some ideas are
very good in particular the idea of meta
tables stood out in this context what
amela tables meta tables is what happens
when you want prototypes and prototype
inheritance but happily you are not
JavaScript it's pretty good actually
now I decided hey I'm gonna enrich
racket not implement tables but enrich
the language with tables so what's a
table table is how many people know lure
tables a few very few all right so
what's a table it's an associative data
structure think keys values hashmaps
hash tables that sort of thing right but
it also provides means of indirection
like prototypes would write so every
table would have a meta table what's
a-matter table it's just a table so a
simple example the simplest example
would be what did what do you do when
the key is missing you look something up
it's not there
well the meta table will decide what to
do yeah that sort of thing so here is a
very prototypical unintended example
with different types of bank accounts
right so we define an account or a table
that's going to be a meta table for
accounts that every account will start
with a balance of zero we define a bunch
of methods what those are those are just
procedural values that happen to be on
the table we just add them there but
there's a fancy syntax to do that for a
meta table and once we have our
prototype inheritance going which is
which which in with lower semantics
would take like two or three lines of
code then we can proceed with more
ambitious accounts like limited account
then add money withdraw money check the
balance they would work for all of those
types yeah that sort of thing so
prototype inheritance going now why I'm
showing you this because the way I
approach doing this I had a couple of
examples in my head some I took from Lua
book right i sat down I didn't have the
language I just started writing
something like this I had an idea of
semantics in my head
so the table tables are created with
curly braces which is no surprise for
closure people but Curly's are not
special in racket so we have to work a
little bit to take them back : balance a
keyword like thing also Q is a special
in racket unlike in closure they're not
well they are self self evaluated but
they're not allowed an expression
position so we need to do something
that that define is obviously somehow
aware of table notation and semantics
like that sort of thing we use : call
call notation in different flavors to
call those methods and all of that stuff
how does that work
they're part of the identifiers by the
way the difference between : : : is that
: : just sends implicitly the receiver
as the first argument that's all
once you have prototypes going you can
become very ambitious and I don't expect
you to read this this is how lure people
would implement multiple inheritance
I was dissatisfied with this example
because it's closed and it's OPAC and
that you can't add and remove meta
tables alright and that led me to a very
different semantics so my first
implementation actually took maybe 200
or 300 lines of code just a bunch of
macros and I had my Lua going completely
for me with all of those fancy syntax
but I change the semantic sense and all
the magic lives in just these three meta
methods there are some some more what a
meta methods they just methods there
were procedures that happen to be tables
that happen to be owned in a meta table
and some names are treated specially
some keys are treated specially I get
when it's there decides what to do when
the key is missing set when it's there
decides what to do when check when the
table changes somehow like you add a key
you remove the key that sort of thing
set meta is only ever called once if
it's present as the final step of the
constructor that lets you like change
the instance you create somehow so that
sort of thing and you can change those
in any way you like another design
decision I made early on is I prohibit
if undefined as the value and the entire
infrastructure works seamlessly to
ensure that this in brain environments
right because you very quickly run into
a question okay how do I signal that
something isn't there okay kind of
pushing it so depending on your answer I
may skip this section although it is an
interesting design symbols quoted
symbols keywords who know
what I'm talking about okay enough
people I'll introduce you to a an
interesting sort of design of racket and
it's it allows for really powerful
tricks so symbols are really overloaded
in scheme and therefore in rackets yeah
we use them for everything
closure made a very good decision of
introducing keywords as sulfa
self-evaluating
datatype now we use keywords for
everything racket made a different
decision its keyword starts with hash :
by the way they are not allowed in
expression position it sounds limiting
but really I came to appreciate this
decision because it makes certain
certain tasks much easier the thing is I
didn't want to choose I want both
so I implemented tags identify as the
start with a colon like keywords in
Common Lisp or Emacs Lisp right or maybe
maybe closure all it took to do that is
this this amount of code I don't expect
you to understand ed but this is where
I'm going to describe a design decision
in in racket that's pretty cool so a
compiler will expand certain forms into
intermediate forms that start with hash
percent like hash on top in this case
right so for instance procedure
application will be always expanded into
intermediate form starting with hash
percent app why is this cool when you
have a unsolvable computer science
problem what do you do
no seriously I'm asking a question
that's right if that doesn't solve it
you don't have enough levels of
interaction right this is kind of what
they did there
the thing is compiler will continue to
expand this form but it will look up the
binding or the meaning for that form at
the call site meaning I can provide my
own semantics you can provide your own
semantics right and that's our clue
because identify unbound I told you
earlier compiler tracks those bindings
right so unbound identifiers get wrapped
into this hash on top thing and we can
take it over that's all it takes to
implement tags it's kind of a hack all
right let's talk very quickly economics
yeah Kelly braces to construct tables we
allow identify in under identifies in
the app position if it's a table it'll
be used as a meta table if it's a
procedure it'll be called on the
instance being created
I also there's an experiment of mine
there's hash sign check followed by
something that's like it lightweight
syntax for traits or mix ends right
there in the constructor and I'll show
you why this I wanted this
we also Ricky tear from racket those
intermediate forms are cool so can we
expand constructor into this
intermediate form hash % table which you
can overtake so you don't have to rely
on me implementing some semantics that
you want of a constructor you can change
it completely and these are all the
flavors of invoking methods on one on
the table or procedural values and stuff
like this yeah and the way you implement
this actually is a bunch of macros the
just leverage hash on top and hash % app
this trick works for this as well very
well
we also expand these into yet another
intermediate form hash and colon which
you can overtake if you like your
closure semantics of looking stuff up go
ahead and implement it I won't object I
don't like it but define is a drop-in
replacement for racket define but it's
aware of all those table notation of all
that table notation it's very convenient
to implement a bunch of methods on a
meta table we extend the racket match so
you can pattern match on
balls obviously how do we provide all of
this unsurprisingly as a language racket
with tables hatchling record with tables
at the top and you have that language
now this is actually something subtle
but very magical because essentially
what just happened is Irie provided all
of racket you have all of record but
augmented with this interesting feature
the language itself is richer for it but
they coexist and this is made possible
by the multi collection packages that
racket provides it's actually really
fancy it's really good all right some
interesting examples of meta tables I
promise to multiple inheritance here's
one it's a possible implementation of
multiple inheritance that's all it takes
just one meta method it's not the only
one but it's open in that you can add
meta tables you can remove meta tables
we can even add we can even we recover
the identity a little bit what exactly
it means that you are this of this type
or not it's up to you to decide but you
can decide it and then implement your
own semantics
I decided ISA will reply hey am I do I
have this meta table somewhere in my
chain or not something like this okay
spec nothing to do with closes back
maybe superficially right it's a good
idea to declare what slots can appear on
a table they do this on the meta table
and that's why I wanted this lightweight
syntax for four traits it comes in
really handy to do things like that spec
itself will not check those
environmental tables open spec and close
back these will enforce the contract
anytime the table changes finally so
tables are actually callable they
already double as procedures and what
exactly this means you get to define
yourself by implementing a proximate of
method you don't have to ask me just do
it yourself if you like what closure is
doing you can do that
I also racket sports actually record
stole a really cool concurrency model
from concurrent ml
it's beautiful with synchronize
implements and threads and all of that
and I wanted for you to be able to use
tables or synchronize moments and for
you to actually customize and decide
what exactly this means to synchronize
on a table so all it takes to implement
this this is one one one place where you
need to sort of drop down to racket is
to define another table like struct type
but then the rest of the ecosystem works
seamlessly with that type of table that
is to say the tables are kind of not
just first class their racket first
class they are aware of the largest
ecosystem which I think is ok as you can
imagine by that time I kind of ran out
of steam right remember we started by
implementing fast CGI have we actually
implemented it well yeah I mean it's not
gonna win any prizes it was almost an
afterthought at this point I kind of got
exhaust exhausted but I have been
running in a fast agile occasion this
entire talk it's in my hand it's this
clicker right here it's it's just a web
page that talks to my passage I back
handwritten in racket and that talks to
my Emacs and drives the presentation and
grabs prompts and sends them back to my
iPhone that's kind of what I did now
obviously it wasn't my intention to
build it but I wanted to show it off
right so we're wishful thinking kind of
approach would work best and this is
actually what I wanted to build in the
first place would be something like a
hash line for writing fast egi script
quick quickly right so writing
implementing a hash line PHP is no
problem at all it's not difficult at all
right but something cleverer than this I
think is possible and just I just don't
have the time to to keep working on that
how we're doing for time all right so
I'm gonna wrap up here there's there are
some stuff that I've been kind of
thinking about and working a little bit
on like immutability which should be
easy to implement dispatch
all things dispatch credit could
dispatch because tables are really cool
for that I think if this sort of thing
interests you come talk to me and I
guess I'm going to leave you with this
it's actually a valid viable strategy in
the language like racket thank you out
of ideas actually even if you're
thinking about building something stop
look around thank you
[Applause]